si guillaume n'échapperait pas vous non
plus à une interview c'est l'interview
fréres passion lequel était le plus
mignon bbc moi ouais il était devant moi
j'étais vilaine mais je m'en fous parce
que la plus jeune c'est lequel des deux
cas la même n'est que son père c'est moi
c'est moi il a été transformé par la vie
vachement bien là aussi c'est lequel le
préféré de maman suivi non je pense pas
non au dessus les as et impartiale c'est
bien et de papa ça dépend des humeurs
ouais ça lui pense qu'il arrange a été
beaucoup moins en moins c'est de quelle
qui aurait aimé être le fils ou la fille
de quelqu'un d'autre moi ah ouais un
lucky de belmondo alain delon économique
hors de vue légal du même chaussé ses
lequel qui était le plus mauvais à
l'école
oui c'est vrai c'est lequel qu'elle
puise en rdc par an chez moi c'est
lequel qu'a voulu faire acteur le
premier ou la première
moi je les fais mais ouais ils vont ils
résister c'est lequel ou laquelle qui
n'a jamais pris de substances illicites
notre question c'est lequel qui protège
l'autre ce mois voici les nains attend
un cd de m
j'étais là plusieurs fois quand les bras
salma j'ai crevé à l'autre jour je vois
c'est le quelques et que l'équipe aux
cadeaux à noël ma personne c'est un
cadeau noël on a fait enfin son frère
ouais quand même un petit colis de temps
en temps c'est le quelques a tourné plus
de navets soit aussi un holà oui il ya
des trucs qui sont même pas sortis ça
fait une chance qui seront graves
séquelles ou laquelle plus engagés
politiquement c'est moi ouais je suis
cultivé ou la plus cultivée
c'est moi aujourd'hui votre contrat vous
qu'ils tirent très restreint oui un
trouble et musicalement tu connais un
maxi c'est tout bah oui madonna
m'intéresse pas bons mais j'étais
rimski-korsakov viger la culture ce que
j'aime c'est petit mince mais je peux
tenir des conversations c'est qu'elle
est plus riche
c'est pas marcel avec les plus riches
que huit fois en battant avons besoin
c'est un verre de voir ses biens c'est
quelqu'un de plus la grosse tête
1 c'est moi je pense oui non mais moi
j'ai toujours été mégalo mais c'est rien
à voir c'est lequel calcul plus
longtemps au père noël personne car ça
c'est lequel qui croient en dieu
incroyable mieux si moi je crois
maintenant je prends un truc monde
écoute de la musique à mes serveurs
avaient été très étonné le toit quand
vous avez dit j'avais osé regarder
dany boon s'est converti au judaïsme en
plus des 9 et 7 ans c'était mon ambition
avant de rencontrer mademoiselle dayan
j'étais en philosophie philosophie
brahic et tous alors oui mais ça nous
laisse penser rien s'est converti au
judaïsme
ah ouais ouais c'est lequel qui en froid
avec papa site one way en ce moment
c'est toi non c'est pas grave mais je
suis contente je me tapais cinq coups de
fil par jour sur
volante d'argent ananas à temps des
vacances
ah ouais je fais ce que j'aime écouter
poliment ce body et bien moi je dis là
j'en peux plus tu vas te garder tes
problèmes voilà chacun sait bien
c'est lundi soir
ce soir ils étaient tous les épisodes